am tropf auf der intensivstation in
fürstenfeldbruck fließt antibiotikum in
die venen der patienten es kann über
leben und tod entscheiden
lungenentzündung hirnhautentzündung
blutvergiftung an diesen krankheiten
sind menschen vor gut 100 jahren noch
gestorben heute ist das anders
im krankenhaus ist extrem wichtig dass
wir antibiotika zur verfügung haben weil
die leben retten gerade wenn man auf
eine intensivstation liegt vielleicht
eine starke entzündung der lunge hat
oder eine entzündung im darm bereich
dann benötigen wir die um einfach zu
vermeiden dass menschen sterben bei
schweren infektionen gibt es oft keine
alternative zum antibiotikum ein problem
deutschland verbraucht es tonnenweise
aber stellt fast keinen wirkstoff mehr
von anfang an selbst her das machen
andere wir sind abhängig von den
chinesen und wenn die die wirkstoffe
nicht mehr liefern für die herstellung
der tabletten dann haben wir ein problem
einer der wichtigsten antibiotika
wirkstoffe cephalosporin den produzieren
nur noch drei große werke auf der welt
alle in china zu den standorten liegt
frontal exklusiv eine karte vor die
professorin ulrike holzgrabe warnt immer
mehr antibiotika wirkstoffe kommen aus
china doch was wenn china nicht mehr
liefert werden wir kein antibiotikum
hätten dann müssen wir von alleine durch
unser immunsystem gesund werden das
gelingt aber bei schweren infektionen
nicht wir würden an infektionen im
großen prozentsätzen sterben also das
wäre sozusagen der super-gau wenn wenn
wir keine antibiotika mehr hätten
china ein autoritäres regime präsident
sea king ping droht mittlerweile
unverhohlen mit militärische aggression
gegen seine nachbarn was können
deutschland und europa dem
entgegensetzen im ernstfall die
wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit von china
ist noch viel größer als die von
russland china hat sich sehr geschickt
in den internationalen lieferketten
positioniert teilweise gewiss auch mit
anderen strategischen gedanken dahinter
und
europäische regierungen auch die
deutsche regierung müssen sich darüber
gedanken machen ob sie nicht in
wichtigen teilbereichen dafür sorgen
dass die produkte die lebensnotwendig
sind in europa hergestellt werden
strategisch relevant sind antibiotika
schon seit ihrer entwicklung in den 1940
er jahren für die alliierten wurden sie
zum kriegs vorteil es starben weniger
soldaten in deutschland dauerte es bis
1950 bis antibiotika im großen stil hier
hergestellt werden konnten der beginn
lag im industriepark frankfurt höchst
bei einer produktion von 400 milliarden
einheiten monatlich können die deutschen
ärzte von nun ab dieses wichtige
heilmittel ohne jede beschränkung
anwenden der industriepark frankfurt
höchst heute werden in den alten
antibiotika anlagen
nahrungsergänzungsmittel für tierfutter
hergestellt
2015 entschied der pharmakonzern
novartis die produktion von
cephalosporin wirkstoffen aufzugeben
obwohl die firma damit gewinne einfuhr
allerdings nicht so hohe wie mit anderen
medikamenten erzählt gewerkschafter ralf
erkens wir haben das damals für einen
fatalen fehler gehalten dass sie
antibiotika produktion hier in höchst
eingestellt wird weil sie für europa
extrem wichtig war wir haben hier ein
hochprofitables werk gehabt was am ende
vielleicht kann ich riesige gewinne
abgeworfen hat aber das produkt gut
herstellen konnte und großen mengen und
insofern glaube ich das war ein fehler
hier eine neue antibiotika produktion
aufzubauen würde fünf bis zehn jahre
dauern wirtschaftlich offenbar nicht
interessant das unternehmen dazu da ist
geld zu verdienen wissen wo man sonst
die nicht aber es gibt auch einen staat
und eine gesellschaft und die muss
diskutieren glaube ich und das ist eine
politische aufgabe wie können wir dafür
sorgen dass es trotzdem
versorgungssicherheit platzen ermitteln
gibt rückblick im märz 2020 als corona
auch über deutschland herein brach gab
der damalige bundesgesundheitsminister
ein versprechen was wir wieder brauchen
sie mehr produktion von arzneimitteln
und wirkstoffen von arzneimitteln in
europa rund zwei jahre später ist nicht
viel passiert doch auch die neue
regierung hat sich im koalitionsvertrag
viel vorgenommen wir brauchen heimische
kapazitäten der medizinischen produktion
um nicht wieder in abhängigkeit zu
geraten
wir fragen nach beim
bundesgesundheitsministerium was nun
genau geplant sein die antwort ziemlich
unkonkret zitat hier bei bedarf es
sowohl gesundheits als auch
wirtschaftspolitischer maßnahmen
die union jetzt in der opposition hat es
da leicht mit forderungen man muss die
ampel koalition endlich liefern und da
helfen keine worthülsen des
bundesgesundheitsministers sondern da
müssen konkrete handlungen jetzt
erfolgen
österreich in kundl in tirol steht ein
werk das den ältesten antibiotika
wirkstoff penicillin herstellt es ist
das einzige europa
1952 wurde in diesem werk das orale
penicillin erfunden als tablette und das
herzustellen ist eine kunst grundlegend
ist der wirkstoff traditionell
hergestellt mit einem schimmelpilz der
ist eigenwillig man kann sich das ein
bisschen vorstellen wie ja ein sehr
sensibles haustier vielleicht also muss
wissen was braucht das tier was muss man
ihn zu füttern welche bedingungen
braucht was schmeckt ihm gut wie hat das
gerne warm und das gern ein bisschen
kälter dieses ganze know how ist das was
uns hier speziell ausmacht
2020 standen die kessel kurz vor dem aus
der konzern novartis der schon
frankfurt-höchst aufgegeben hatte drohte
auch in österreich mit dem ende der
antibiotika wirkstoffproduktion trotz
gewinnen doch die österreichische
regierung konnte den konzern um stimmen
die penicillin produktion bleibt in
österreich in kunde die aktuelle krise
zeigt uns dass die pharmazeutische
industrie zu den schlüsselindustrien in
österreich und in europa zählt und dass
wir hier im moment eine klare
abhängigkeit von medikamenten
produktionen und versorgungen aus asien
haben der wir entgegenwirken müssen das
ließ sich die regierung 50 millionen
euro kosten das werk wird jetzt weiter
ausgebaut die hilfe vom staat freud in
österreich chef von novartis es ist sehr
bemerkenswert dass es hier zu einem
schulterschluss zwischen politik und
industrie unternehmen gekommen ist es
ist extrem wichtig die
schlüsseltechnologien in europa zu
halten und darauf müssen wir uns
fokussieren doch ein kunde wird nur der
wirkstoff penicillin hergestellt bei
anderen überlebenswichtigen antibiotika
wirkstoffen hängen deutschland und
europa nach wie vor an chinas tropf